адже початку лютого український президент
вже в стик побувати і прибрали нею
німецькі парламентарі пориві рило
хитрий форму києву партнерства світ
україну це фарин з тобою тему та
публічної дискусії інституту світлове
політикою вбивши торак за ваш тонким ще
правда патча сорому минула інша харчування
урядовий щур так представлений розуміти
як ділових kill в україні Олександр
маркус skoda я про вигляд ставку міністра
економіки та його раса абрамово години за
роком граків мінус там у можу навіть дол
кидки проти лис міністром економіка
абромавічус він мент вже дуже ряху опишу
у нас монако la проблеми
алавіт ставка міністра на травень без
посередників пливу на економіку можна
вована спливаючи на бача не знімай чини
може його на інвесторі iv столітті 23 палів не
зустрічався з ним особисто про там і віру
потужністю прем'єр-міністр призначить нового
не дешевого міністром почавши миль країни
призначення з однак мої рингу тася
шведку abc.az далекий від німецької
економіки а джоні сноу з поста лягає
Інтера знімати який проект в до
україни а для приватних інвесторів важливі
ваза крима стабільність у ряді
там є у чикаго не західних держав
інвесторів через 2 руки писали
євромайдану в його суть більше а-j дає
цифру мільярд не вкладаючи в Україну
піцою одного з а ви не каїди дали
більше сум не крутиться у ряду
реформатор бджоли шиви до помсти бажання
працювати реформи
а нас правді старого добре структура
членом місці відсіювали шаленим для
петренко заходу захисту від 3 травня реформа
на україну і ок так у
теж чого україна не до монстра, а там
ще он вона вірному шляху те й бити
ринки у західних столицях менші
причому видається на вище про політичну
пит ринку ой про фінансову допомогу
україні